The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'll do
the Vanna White thing.
So this sucks in air
here, and inside,
57% of methane or other
combustible gases in it.
And it sucks in about I
think half liter a minute.
And so you can get a
percent gas in the air.
And so luckily, at the moment,
there's probably 0% methane.
AUDIENCE: Is that what
gas companies quickly
use to find leaks?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
yeah, they normally
have a big probe on it.
And what they do is they
take bang bar, which
is like a big stick and
they stick it in the ground
until they get a
hole, and then they
stick this with a probe
on it, suck air in
and figure out what the
percent gas is in the soil.
Then they know by where
the highest percentage
is in the soil.
They figure, OK, that's
probably where the leak is,
and they start digging there.
So it's a really simple
and fantastic tool.
CGI, yeah, combustible
gas indicator.
PROFESSOR: And right here
is where the inlet is,
OK, just off of here.
We do this-- it's better to
do it than in the back bumper,
because there can be some
exhaust contamination.
Actually, well, two cars, we've
tested it, do not interfere,
but this is a little
bit of an old van.
So sometimes-- I mean, it
passed the emissions test,
but still there can
be some contamination.
That's why when we
stopped, sometimes you'll
get some measurements, but
when you're moving forward
and the wind is upstream, you
know you're getting readings.
This is the methane
reading that analyzers
are reading right now.
So it's anything below
2, it's right now,
1.96 is pretty clean.
There's no leak where
we are right now.
So if it's under 2, you know
we're in a place with no leak.
And even if it creeps up over
2, if it's like 2.01, 2.02,
that's not really
indicative of a leak.
But if you see it
go up to like 2,
your eyes can tell you
in time that oh, it
seems to be going up
pretty rapidly here.
And so you'll see it maybe
go for 2.3 sometimes,
and then drop back down.
And that's kind of unusual.
That's like, OK, there's
probably something around here.
And then every once
in a while, you
might see something that goes
up further, 3, 3 and 1/2,
and those are like
definite leaks.
AUDIENCE: What's the highest
number you've ever seen?
PROFESSOR: Well, in
DC, we got I think very
near to 100 parts per million.
And that's in the air
that we're breathing,
so it's not explosive
at that level.
But it's like 50 times more
than the background value.
AUDIENCE: So 2 is baseline
kind of background.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah,
you can consider 2
to be a baseline level.
Now it's like CO2, well, it used
to be 280 parts per million,
and now it's like over 400.
So 2 parts per million
methane is the new normal.
I mean it was 0.7 parts
per million, preindustrial.
So I would like
to point that out
that are our normal
baseline is very abnormal.
So we're going up
about that with leaks.
Now this is a timeline
here, this graph,
and you can see as I came
in here, we did get 6, 7,
we got a few leaks here.
And that was right at the
Allston/Brighton tolls
coming down off
of the Mass Pike.
There's a leak there.
AUDIENCE: So what happens
in terms the reporting
that or following up with it?
PROFESSOR: So we don't
have any evidence,
but based on driving by.
We can't say whether it's
a green one hazardous leak,
a grade two, or a grade three
so-called non-hazardous leak.
So I don't feel
obligated that each
what we see that OK, we got
to call the gas company.
First of all, they do
know about these leaks.
They know-- to a large
degree where they are.
But if we get out, and we
could, because we have the CGI.
If we decide to get out and
poke around and look through it,
and we find evidence that
it is like a grade one,
then that's when I feel
obligated to call the leak in.
'Cause it's like
we have knowledge
that something
seems to be unsafe,
and so then we call it in.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Is there
a clear indicator
when it's a grade one?
PROFESSOR: This
machine is not going
to be able to tell us whether
there's a grade one, a grade
explosive hazard, grade
two, or grade three.
And that's because you can
have big leaks with lots of gas
coming out that are
not explosive hazards.
Like the Porter
Ranch gas leak in LA,
Audrey makes this point
a lot, it was technically
a grade three
non-hazardous leak,
'cause it wasn't
going to explode.
And it wasn't that close
to the neighborhood,
it was like a quarter mile
away from the neighborhood.
So it's an indication
that that grading scheme
is only a single
variable grading scheme.
And explosion and
hazard is a big deal.
There's no doubt about
that, and no one wants that.
So what the grading
scheme has to incorporate
the amount of the flux.
There is a GPS on
this roof right now,
and it's plugged into
the back of the machine,
and the data file that comes out
is already integrated with GPS
with the time stamp.
Straight?
AUDIENCE: Left, if we can, yep.
So what are the
objectives for today?
Is it just to see how
methane is measured,
or are we trying to answer
any particular questions?
PROFESSOR: So what we call
this is a gas leak safari.
So one of the objectives--
OK, here we are, 2, 3, 2, 3,
so there's something there.
So just to educate
and to show first
of all what this process is
of mapping the gas leaks.
I think that we're going to
places that we have surveyed
in the past, Audrey and Heat did
the study now, two years ago,
is it?
But things change.
AUDIENCE: Take a right here.
PROFESSOR: Right on Portland.
2.1, 2.1, OK, here we
have something, 2.1.
So there's something
here I think.
AUDIENCE: 2.3.
AUDIENCE: 2.5.
2.7.
PROFESSOR: OK,
yeah, read them out.
AUDIENCE: 2.8.
PROFESSOR: OK, so there's a
leak here in this facility.
AUDIENCE: Portland and Main.
AUDIENCE: So that's at 2.3.
Oh, 3.3, well, 4.4, 4.4.
AUDIENCE: 4.2.
3.8.
PROFESSOR: So you
can see there's
the spike on the leading edge.
Right?
It's really as you can imagine,
as any lay person can imagine,
the vagaries of wind
are going to the plume.
The plume is coming out of
wherever it can come out.
I could come out of
a man hole slot--
straight on?
AUDIENCE: Straight on.
PROFESSOR: It could
come out of the soil.
A leak is going to to just
find whatever parallel
pathways it can get out.
And so you can
imagine, at the surface
there's some kind of profile
of this stuff coming out.
And then the wind's going to
carry it and blow it around.
And so that makes
it a little tough.
We can't really
pinpoint exactly where
it's coming out of the ground.
We can know when we
have driven by it.
There's a leak in this
vicinity, and I would always
say within 50 to
100 feet of where
we measured it is probably
part of the source coming
on the ground.
But to actually really pinpoint
where the pipeline leak is
would require stopping, getting
out, and using the instrument
that Audrey has as well as
maybe some other instruments,
handheld snippers to really
find out where it's coming out.
What you're realizing right
now that makes it like discreet
when we see a leak, if you
look at this timeline here,
this trace, you can see
there's a lot of flat
and then some fairly
well resolved spikes.
And so it's not very
ambiguous when you get
an elevated anomalous reading.
It's like, oh, there's one,
there's one, there's one.
Here's a couple that are
small, but they really
need to go very clearly
from the back ground.
So there's not that much
ambiguity about like, well,
is this kind of giant
blob a leak or not?
They're well resolved
spikes in time and space.
AUDIENCE: What's
the biggest leak
you've seen in the Boston area?
PROFESSOR: Maybe like 40 or 50
parts per million in the air.
AUDIENCE: Where was that?
PROFESSOR: Well, a couple of
places that were close to that.
One was Sullivan Square,
Rutherford Street
in Charles Town, kind of on
the Somerville Charles Town
border, the giant rotary.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I mean, we
could go over there,
there is a big leak there.
And then Nonantum Road between
kind of Watertown and Newton.
2.2, 2.3, OK, so there's
something here, OK.
2.3, OK, so we've got, 2.5.
AUDIENCE: 2.5.
AUDIENCE: 2.8.
3.
3.2.
4.8.
AUDIENCE: 6.
AUDIENCE: Oh boy.
Oh boy.
AUDIENCE: 5.3.
PROFESSOR: So I mean, we
could get out and take a break
and find it if you
wanted on this one.
It's kind of quiet.
This is definitely a
much blunter instrument
than that one.
And it's made to find out
like percent level, 50%, 10%,
not parts per million.
OK, so this is now when
you want to find out
where is it coming out at, OK?
The professionals right
now would have this bar,
it's called a bang bar.
It's like one of those
construction pile drivers,
it's like a handheld
version of that.
And you would find out,
maybe right here, you'd
like slam it down
maybe up to a meter.
And this would have
a longer thing,
and you'd stick it in there.
Now I don't do that, because
I'm not certified to do that,
and I don't want to
puncture any gas lines
and create an explosion.
So what I do is I just
kind of do like this,
and sometimes I'll use like
a screwdriver or just a stick
even, and kind of--
this is right at the surface--
and poke around.
So actually look, there
is something, point 0.2.
Now the fact, 0.25%.
So 0.25% is, let's see, 1%
is 10,000 parts per million,
right, 1% is 10, 000
parts per million.
This is 8,500 parts
per million right now--
0.85, 0.9.
OK, so the thing is that
this is right at the surface.
If I was down even
probably that much,
it would probably be
I don't know 15%, 20%.
And if we went down a little
further, this could be 90% gas.
See this is 0.25.
Yeah, so about the same.
I'm just like about that far in.
So this is an indication that
there's definitely a leak here.
And it's no mistake we got
the 15 parts per million
in the kind of air
that we're breathing.
So now let's look around
for just infrastructure.
Let's see I mean, that was
a very arbitrary choice
of a place to look.
It's just we got
out, we're here.
But now I want to see like,
OK, where is the gas line?
AUDIENCE: And all that.
PROFESSOR: That could be a
vestige of a gas leak marking.
And this big patch has
been for some purpose,
I don't know if
it was a gas line.
I see some more
yellow paint out here.
OK, so this is --
OK, yeah, always be very
careful with the cars of course.
So this is a service line
coming off of the main, OK?
So service lines going this way,
mains generally going that way.
Mains can be at
an angle, they can
be running under the sidewalk,
so anything can really happen.
AUDIENCE: So were
mains laid down
before the streets were
gridded or something or what?
PROFESSOR: Or
sometimes afterwards.
AUDIENCE: OK, but
if it's afterwards,
I'm going to assume that there--
configures to the street.
PROFESSOR: They probably
would do it running that way
if it was done afterwards.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: This is an
electrical manhole.
The gas can come in any--
it can seep in anywhere.
So 0.25, OK, so gas in there.
All right, so we did this.
OK so, all right, so there's
definitely gas in here.
That's very, very clear.
I mean, if you
really wanted to, you
could smell, and smell
the gas, but I'm not
going to recommend that.
But this is not an
explosive thresh hold.
So I don't feel like, back
off, don't smoke or whatever.
Well, don't smoke,
but if it were 4%,
then that would be a grade
one explosive hazard, OK?
And we would call
it in, and they
would come out immediately,
well, within a half hour or so.
AUDIENCE: And again, 4%
is what on that readout?
PROFESSOR: 40,000
parts per million.
4% is equal to 40,000
So if the 4.0, that's
40,000 parts per million.
And that's the lower
explosion threshold,
the higher explosion
threshold is about 15% gas.
If it gets above that,
there's not enough oxygen
for it to explode.
PROFESSOR: All right,
where little kids are
like playing in the
playground, there's a grade one
leak under a manhole,
we call it in,
and these two guys
from Evershore
arrive, and they don't
even have like a bang bar,
and they didn't have the right
instrumentation to do anything.
So we pop open the
manhole for them.
And they look and
they're like, yeah.
Then we go off to the
side, and they actually
said in front of
me, because I don't
think they realized that
I wasn't a utility person,
they're like, yeah, you
just got to think sometimes,
an explosion is the
price of using gas.
And like the kids are behind
us playing in the playground.
AUDIENCE: It wasn't a
facetious comment, huh?
PROFESSOR: No, it was an--
AUDIENCE: Like it comes
with the territory?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
and I mean, yeah, it
was sort of, in
front of the kids,
I just thought that
was really strange.
AUDIENCE: So did they do
something [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: They did fix it
after a while, what Bob said,
but they didn't fix
it at that point.
AUDIENCE: That's the
highest we've seen.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, 1, 1, 1,
it just exceeded 1, 1.2.
So the gas company, so 2.2.
OK, so this is too close to this
tree to be good for this tree.
And clearly this
tree is not that old.
How long ago did they
put this in here,
how much did it cost
to put this in here?
And now you've got a leak here.
And this white paint, that's a
sign of the gas company having
been out here at some
point to monitor.
Here's the service line.
So I don't know, I mean--
AUDIENCE: Sorry if I
missed this earlier,
but why does methane
kill the tree?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, sorry.
The methane, the natural
gas has no oxygen in it.
And the root systems need
oxygen to metabolize,
so you've got this plume
of anoxic soil volume,
and it kills the roots.
AUDIENCE: So in
fact, right here,
isn't it the case that there
could have been an older tree
the same age as
these tall ones that
died and was replaced by this.
And possibly it died
because of methane leak.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I mean, it would
be very interesting to find out
what the history of this is,
because this is I
don't know, this
is maybe two to
three years old is
my guess from the sampling
from whatever it was planted.
So OK, I'm not getting anything
at the very surface here,
but we definitely
got some there.
And that's two too close to
this tree, because I mean,
the root system is
certainly going over there.
Another really interesting
thing, so it actually
does come back to being--
so I'm a tree
physiologist actually.
That's what I'm
suppose to be doing,
that's why I got
into this stuff.
But it's interesting,
because some trees have
a vasculature that
is called segmented,
and some tree species have an
integrated vascular structure.
What that means is that some
species, the roots on this side
are connected to the pipes
that run water on this side
and are connected to the
branches on the side.
And then this side operates
kind of like as a parallel path.
Whereas other trees
species like pine,
a lot of the pine species, it's
like whatever comes out of here
or goes through here could have
been from anywhere in the soil,
it's integrated, OK,
spatially integrated.
So if the gas leak has
some spatial pattern to it,
you could see differences in
where it shows up on the tree
depending on the tree species
and its vascular structure.
Look at this, look
how it's breaking off,
like the twigs
are just snapping.
This tree is not in
good, it's dried out.
And so this is not, this
tree is having problems.
You can just, I mean, I'm
not killing this tree,
it's just like
these tips are dead.
They're not hydrated.
AUDIENCE: Well, this one's OK.
OK,
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
these are OK over here.
This side is not doing so good.
So I don't know.
AUDIENCE: So it's something
that you envisioned
citizen scientist doing
like measuring for methane
and trace the problem
for their trees,
and then reporting it to
the city or reporting it--
PROFESSOR: Totally, yeah.
And that's the whole idea behind
making this available through
heat by the Sierra Club, I'm
on the executive committee
of the Sierra Club, so I'm
like promoting the Sierra Club.
But they're making these things
available for communities
to do what we're doing,
to use your nose,
to use your eyes to find.
People will walk by it's
like, oh, I smell a leak,
and then you can go and
check this out and actually
find out where it is,
and then report it.
You don't have to wait to
report it if you smell a leak,
you can and should report it.
But it empowers you
to find out more.
And Mothers Out Front has been
amazing in terms of also--
it's not just what
they know, but when
they plant that
flag in the ground,
it's showing everyone else that
there's a leak here as well.
So just essentially
making the problem
transparent to everyone.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So Mothers Out
Front has had and maybe
still do a campaign
where there's a leak,
they just plant a
yellow flag, and it
has a sniffing nose on it and
it basically makes it clear
that there's a leak there.
AUDIENCE: We did in a
concentrated time period,
and then we collected
the flags back again.
But during that process, a
lot of people talked with us
and were reading the
information that we left
attached to the flag--
AUDIENCE: Did the
utility companies
respond to those
flags at all per se?
AUDIENCE: Not in any
way that we know.
Audrey might know
a little bit more.
We didn't do any
measurements, we were just
going from the mapping
that had been done,
and we were given points
where there was more
significant leakage going on.
PROFESSOR: And so
that was actually
driven by information
provided by the utilities.
But like a follow on
development of this could be--
'cause we know that the leak map
provided by the utilities, as
good as Audrey did to
put them faithfully
down where they were looking.
The utilities get
it wrong sometimes,
or these missing leaks--
what are we calling them?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, missing leaks.
PROFESSOR: Missing leaks
that have come off the books.
And it doesn't seem like
they like 15% of them
came off like on December
31st, it doesn't make sense.
So it's kind of
auditing them as well.
And this is just us
being parked here, OK?
So you can see it going up
and down and up and down,
and that again, is just the
wind wafting this leak around.
So it gives you an idea of
the vagaries of the weather
conditions.
But you can see also that even
when it goes down, I mean,
the lowest it ever went
here is like, I don't know,
2.7 or maybe 3 or so.
So it's obviously a leak.
But depending on the conditions,
I mean, we were up above 16, we
we're down to like 3.
And so if you drive a
leak two different times,
you're going to get two
different peak readings.
That's part of the
thing that makes
it difficult to estimate like
really how big the leak is.
This is still the
Swiss Alps of leaks.
OK, here's the school.
AUDIENCE: What are you at?
PROFESSOR: 2.4, 3.3, OK, so
there's a leak right here
at the school, 2.37.
So when you see it
dip down like that
and then come back up like
that, that's pretty clear.
We're moving at a steady pace
here, so got a leak here.
I didn't pay attention
to the trees.
AUDIENCE: 4.
PROFESSOR: 4, OK.
Some young trees, patches.
AUDIENCE: 3.8, 3.4, 2.9.
PROFESSOR: OK, that
tree [INAUDIBLE]..
All right, so leaks there.
9.
We got 9.
AUDIENCE: 12.
PROFESSOR: 11.
AUDIENCE: 11.
PROFESSOR: You
want to pull over?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: And you see the
yellow markings everywhere,
and that's always gas,
the yellow is gas.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yellow
always refers to gas.
Blue is water.
PROFESSOR: So it's like you
see stuff every time that's
just a little different.
Like I don't know if I've
ever seen a marking like right
on a curbstone like
that for [INAUDIBLE]..
I guess that's the
arrow [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but there
seems to one here too,
so are there two 12 inch
mains running down the street
that way underneath us.
PROFESSOR: You have
multiple mains.
Oh, I think of
bracketing it here.
So you can see the
two yellow lines.
But here it is,
12 inch cast iron.
Cast iron is the
old leaky stuff.
It's the most leak prone, most
prevalent leak prone pipe.
PROFESSOR: So with
cast iron, they
way they originally
did it is they
put jute, which is sort of a
grass, between the two joint--
to close the joints.
And then as gas got
less humid, because they
decreased the humidity of
the gas, that jute dried out.
And so they're basically
almost all cast iron
has problems, every 12
feet, because of that.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
PROFESSOR: Let's see if we
get anything out of here.
PROFESSOR: Nathan and
Bob Ackley went out to--
PROFESSOR: All that
work and we got nothing.
So it's not [INAUDIBLE].
Now these are drill holes,
so kind of push it there
and see if you get anything.
Just hold it down,
you'll hear it slow down,
the pump slow down if
you push it too hard.
OK, nothing there.
So drill holes are for the gas
company when they come out.
OK, let's come out
quick and try these.
All right, so let's go out
here and let's just test--
let's stick it in one of
these things real quick.
Leave it in for
about 10 seconds.
And maybe someone can make
sure we don't get hit.
Keep an eye out.
AUDIENCE: OK, there we go.
40.4.
PROFESSOR: Keep it in there.
Keep it in there.
AUDIENCE: Cars coming.
PROFESSOR: All
right, we can get up.
OK, so definitely gas in there.
OK, so yeah, we
didn't really find--
we found the leak, but we didn't
find any large concentration.
AUDIENCE: It might have
been a little further
down the block, the scent.
PROFESSOR: I mean, it's all
along this block, so yeah.
This is relatively new,
right, look at the line
where the new paving was.
This intersection was redone
with a new everything,
we got gas.
So this is an example
of a lost opportunity.
PROFESSOR: With MAPC, he did
a study to sort of figure
out how much municipalities
and gas companies could
save by doing sort of more
integrated infrastructure
repair and not
screwing up like this.
AUDIENCE: Here comes a, yep.
PROFESSOR: And it
was like $1 billion.
You can check it out
and fixourpipes.org.
It's a really beautiful website.
PROFESSOR: So it was
just a little bit.
But there is gas, I
mean, so that's not good.
PROFESSOR: So you
can sort of imagine
like all the infrastructure
underneath, both the gas
pipes and the electric and
the water mains and stuff
like that, as well
as the paving.
And the paving alone
in Massachusetts
I think is $600,000
on average per mile.
So it's just expense layered
on expense on expense.
And so if you fix anything,
if you cut into the pavement
for any reason, you should just
fix all of it at the same time.
'Cause otherwise,
it's like operating
on somebody's appendix and
finding a broken artery,
and be like, oh, whatever.
Forget that, we'll take care
of that some other time.
Not our responsibility.